ANKUR KOTWAL: Welcome to part
three of the "DevByte" series
"Making Apps Beautiful."
I'm Ankur Kotwal.
Thus far, we've been focused on
making our list reader app
beautiful on phones, but we
haven't really looked at the
tablet side of things.
So let's see if we just take
that app that we've been using
so far and put it on a tablet.
Let's see what it looks like.
So we have a Nexus 10 here
with the app running.
And you'll see it's
not particularly
attractive at all.
There's all this wasted white
space on the right-hand side.
And then when I go into the
Detail view, the text is going
edge to edge.
Sure, the fonts are nice, and
we've modernized it with an
Action bar.
But this isn't a great
tablet experience.
So let's switch back
to the slides.
Let's talk about
what we can do.
And really, the obvious thing to
do in this situation is to
implement a two-pane UI.
So we're going to go from
something like what you see
here to something like this,
where we have both the list
items on the left-hand side and
the detailed items on the
right-hand side.
The way we're going to do that
is we're going to try and
basically keep or reuse as much
of the code as possible.
We don't want to write a phone
version and a tablet version
of the apps.
That's not how you build
Android apps.
So we're going to use a little
trick called XML references.
So let's look at the code
on my machine here.
We have our two activities,
the list activity and the
detail activity.
But you'll notice we've also
got a layout here for a
two-pane activity.
Now, one way to load this is
that when we load the initial
activity, the list activity, we
could just, at that point,
work out whether we're a tablet
or not and load the
two-pane layout.
We're not going to do that.
We're going to use this XML
references trick that I
particularly like.
So we're still going
to load Activity
Article List as our layout.
But we're going to specify this
refs.xml file, and that
name isn't special.
We're just calling it that.
But what is special is we're
going to check in on a
directory called values,
smallest width, 600dp-land.
The smallest width 600 dp
basically tells us that this
is a tablet.
That's a metric that we use.
The Land tells us we're
in Landscape Mode.
So in Landscape Mode on a
tablet, we're going to load
this refs.xml.
And this file has the activity
article list.
And what we're saying is if you
refer to a layout called
Activity Article List, instead
of returning what's already
there in your resource folder,
return a different layout.
So load this layout here,
activity_article_twopane.
So again, we've done it all in
XML without actually having to
change any Java.
And we'll get the
right layout.
We'll get the two-pane layout,
which is great.
But we're not done yet, because
we actually need to
make one more change, which is
when the user selects an item
from that list view, we
shouldn't launch another
activity into their
detailed view.
What we should be doing is
selecting or replacing that
right-hand fragment.
So what we're going to do is
actually in our article list
activity, we're going to work
out if we're in two-pane mode.
There's multiple ways you can do
this, so we're not going to
go into it in a great
amount of detail.
But once you know if you're
working in two-pane mode, all
you're doing is basically when
the list item is selected,
you're going to get your
Fragment Manager and replace
that detail fragment with
the relevant one.
If you're in single-pane mode,
you're just going to go and
call the start activities.
So on phones, we'll start
a new activity.
On tablets, we'll just replace
that fragment on the
right-hand side.
Simple as that, we have
our two-pane UI.
Of course, this is all based on
the assumption that you are
already using fragments.
If you're not using fragments
in your app already, I think
you're making a mistake.
It's really important
that you do so.
It allows you to make these apps
really flexible depending
on the form factor.
And you'll see we did it
with minimal effort.
So let's switch back
to our slide.
And what we're seeing
now, we've got our
nice two-pane UI--
great.
But one thing that's still
lacking here is spacing.
Those margins that we specified
on either side for
the detail view, they
don't seem as
applicable for a tablet.
And in fact, even our List
view seems a little bit
squashed, or more so
than it should be.
So what we're going to do is
actually, we're going to go
and override some of those
values for tablets.
So switching back to the code,
you'll recall that we had a
dimensions XML file that we'd
specified for our List views.
We'd had some top and
bottom margins.
And for our detailed
view, we had some
margins on either side.
What we're going to do is
specify another dimensions
file for tablets, 600 dp.
And we don't care whether it's
portrait or landscape.
We're going to use
these dimensions.
And instead of 8 and 16, we're
going to go 16 dps vertically,
for margin, for the List view,
and 80 dps on either side.
So now let's switch back to
slides and see what that will
actually end up achieving.
This is what we have now.
When we put those new margins
in, we've got much better
spacing vertically between our
list items on the left and on
either side in the detailed
view as well.
So with that being said, we've
now come to the end of this
checkpoint, which is this is
where we started with our
tablet app--
not very attractive at all.
And this is where
we've come to.
So the next part, we're
going to focus
on performance tuning.